Вітаю! З вами я, Олена Соляник –
викладач біології школи «Майбутні».
У домашньому завданні я просила
знайти різні визначення виду
і спробувати їх застосувати
до різних груп організмів.
Якщо ви це зробили, то змогли
помітити наступну картину:
немає жодних проблем із
рослинами, тваринами, навіть,
одноклітинними еукаріотами, хоча
тут вже з’являються деякі нюанси.
Але ми будемо бачити проблему у
визначенні виду бактерій і особливо –
у визначенні виду вірусів,
оскільки ми не можемо застосувати
звичні нам рамки про вільне схрещування.
Для бактерій відоме явище
переносу, коли бактерії різних видів
можуть передавати свою
ДНК від однієї бактерії до іншої.
До речі, таким чином бактерії
набувають стійкості до антибіотиків.
І деякі інші механізми, тобто,
виходить, що в межах цієї групи
ми не можемо виокремити вид як вид,
оскільки порушена умова
вільного схрещування між собою.
Ну і щодо вірусів – ми
взагалі будемо мати проблему,
оскільки віруси поза
клітиною не розмножуються.
А розмножуються вони
не паруючись один з одним,
а а клонуючи себе
всередині клітини хазяїна.
Тобто, тут дійсно будемо мати
проблему з визначенням виду.
І сьогодні ми з 9 класом роздивляємося
наступну тему в курсі «Еволюція» -
це «Розвиток еволюційних
поглядів і докази еволюції».
Як же ставилися до еволюційного
процесу у різні історичні часи?
Ну і, власне, які ж докази ми
маємо щодо цього процесу?
Почнемо з історії. До XVIII
століття панувала така думка,
що види не змінюються і що їх
утворена якась певна кількість.
Вони існують вічно, без жодних змін.
І утворилися вони завдяки
якимось вищим силам.
Навіть якщо знаходилися
якісь викопні рештки випадково,
то ці рештки приписували
міфічним істотам,
існування яких було під питанням: чи
то реальна історія була, чи не реальна.
Така ситуація відбувалася
доволі довго, до XVIII століття.
Сьогодні, незважаючи на всі
досягнення нашої сучасної науки,
є прихильники такої теорії.
Вони існують і досить жваво
відстоюють свою точку зору,
ведуть якісь запеклі суперечки
з прихильниками більш пізніх, більш
прогресивних еволюційних теорій.
У 1809 році виходить праця Жана Батиста
Ламарка під назвою «Філософія зоології».
І про що він там пише?
Він пише про те, що види змінюються.
У який бік види змінюються?
Види змінюють для того,
щоб стати досконалішими.
Тобто, за його переконаннями,
є якесь внутрішнє прагнення
до самовдосконалення, під
впливом якого ці зміни відбуваються.
На види впливають умови довкілля.
Ну, ви, мабуть, бачили
у своїх підручниках
класичний приклад із
ламарківськими жирафами.
За його теорією, вони,
харчуючись листям на деревах,
змушені були дотягуватися до нього.
І для того, щоб дістати
листя з верхніх гілок,
вони були змушені вправляти свої органи.
Таким чином, поступово у
них подовжувалися кінцівки
і сьогодні ми маємо сучасних жирафів – це
найвища антилопа в африканській савані.
По-перше, зрозуміло, що
ця теорія більш прогресивна.
Вона пояснює більше різноманітних
біологічних механізмів,
аніж погляди креаціоністів.
За Ламарком, оскільки кожен
організм еволюціонує тому,
що прагне до досконалості,
життя самозароджується постійно.
Перша критика, яку
хочеться надати цій теорії –
це якби життя самозароджувалося постійно,
то різні живі форми відрізнялися б
за своєю фундаментальною будовою.
Але такого не відбувається.
Всі проаналізовані живі
форми на нашій планеті
побудовані за єдиним принципом.
І дослідження доводять, що всі організми
виникли від єдиного спільного предка.
Тобто, ніякого багатократного,
багаторазового зародження
у природі не відбувається.
Звичайно, Ламарк про це не
знав, але ж ми про це знаємо.
Другий момент, на рахунок якого
хочеться висловити заперечення:
за його теорією, організмами
унаслідуються набуті ознаки.
Навіть розглядаючи
його приклад із жирафами,
якщо жирафа якимсь чином
займалася вправлянням своєї шиї
для того, щоб дотягнутися
до верхніх листків,
то вона має передати цю
ознаку своїм нащадкам.
Але ж ми знаємо, що передаються
нащадкам не усі ознаки,
а лише ті, зміни в яких потрапили не
до будь-якої клітини, а лише до статевої.
Адже при розмноженні передається
інформація лише статевих клітин.
Тобто, це такі місця, які не
дозволяють цілком прийняти цю теорію.
Але за часів Ламарка це
було надзвичайно прогресивно.
І в 1859 році вийшла
знаменита праця Дарвіна
«Про походження видів
шляхом природного добору».
Дарвін взагалі відкрив
свою теорію випадково.
І ця випадковість була
у тому, що він потрапив
до навколосвітньої
подорожі на кораблі «Бігль».
Під час цієї подорожі корабель
зупинявся на Галапагоських остовах.
І Галапагоські остови просто вразили
Дарвіна своєю різноманітністю видів,
які мешкали на кожному з цих островів.
Від відзначав, що види
подібні на різних островах,
але строго індивідуальні на
кожному окремому острові.
У вашому підручнику є картинка з
класичними дарвінівськими в’юрками.
Він досліджував форму дзьоба
цих в’юрків і з’ясував наступне:
в’юрки потрапили і розселилися
Галапагоськими островами.
На кожному острові вони змушені були
пристосовуватися до умов
окремо взятого острова
і обирати собі свою харчову базу.
І ось, на одних островах ці в’юрки
пристосувалися до рослинної їжі,
на інших – до тваринної, вони стали
комахоїдними і змінили форму дзьоба.
То був надзвичайний прогрес.
Тобто, Дарвін визнавав,
що види змінюються,
Дарвін визнавав, що
існує природний добір,
який безпосередньо керує
процесом відбору найпристосованіших.
Таким чином, шляхом поступового
відбору найпристосованіших форм
відбувається власне еволюція видів.
Але пізніше була оприлюднена
теорія «переривчастої еволюції»,
яка каже про те, що
за різких змін довкілля
зміни в організмах
відбуваються стрибкоподібно
і одразу виникає їх
величезна кількість змін.
Вони надалі підпадають
під дію природного добору
і за рахунок цього відбираються
вже найпристосованіші форми.
Якщо проаналізувати історію
розвитку життя на нашій Землі,
то десь приблизно так і відбувається.
Після якихось великих катаклізмів
стрибкоподібно, дуже раптово
з’являється величезна кількість видів, які
надалі вже під ці умови підлаштовуються.
Дарвін цього в своїй теорії
пояснити не міг, адже звичайно,
на той час він не володів таким
великим об’ємом інформації.
Наразі панує синтетична теорія
еволюції, яка каже про те, що:
в популяціях відбуваються зміни
на рівні генетичного матеріалу,
вони закріплюються в цьому генотипі
і здатні передаватися нащадкам;
ці зміни підпадають під
дію природного добору;
що одиницею цього
процесу є саме популяція;
ці зміни призводять до
утворення нових видів.
Ну тут ще один момент:
розглядають мікроеволюцію,
тобто процес еволюційний, який
закінчується утворенням виду,
і розглядають макроеволюцію,
що закінчується утворенням
більш великих таксонів.
Які ж є докази?
Перш за все, ми можемо використовувати
дані порівняльної анатомії.
Якщо ми порівняємо, наприклад,
внутрішню будову усіх хребетних.
Ми побачимо, що принциповий
план будови однаковий:
є хребет, череп,
кінцівки, є системи органів,
які відповідають за дихання,
за харчування, за виділення,
за статевий процес,
кровоносна система тощо.
Тобто, всі споріднені між собою
організми мають подібний план будови.
І це є доказом того, що вони колись
мали спільного предка з такими ознаками.
Якщо ми проаналізуємо
будь-яку групу живих організмів,
ми зможемо ці ознаки
порівняти і з’ясувати
по-перше, яка група була
родоначальником всіх цих організмів,
по-друге, приблизно
прорахувати, коли це могло статися.
І зараз вчені саме цим займаються.
Дані порівняльної ембріології.
Якщо ми порівняємо
ембріони різних тварин,
то зможемо побачити наступне:
на ранніх стадіях розвитку
усі ембріони дуже-дуже схожі.
Це помітили вже дуже
давно, цю схожість ембріонів.
Такий вчений Геккель запропонував закон,
за яким онтогенез повторює філогенез.
Тобто, живий організм протягом
свого індивідуального розвитку
повторює свій історичний розвиток.
Це означає, що є певний
геологічний час появи,
історичний час появи
якихось певних ознак.
Не все з’являється одночасно.
І ембріон у своєму
розвитку ці стадії проходить.
Дані палеонтології.
За часів Дарвіна палеонтологія
як наука не була розвинена.
У нього не було достатньої
кількості доказів своєї теорії.
Це було приводом для критики, щоб
намагатися спростувати цю теорію.
Наразі відомо набагато
більше викопних решток,
і аналізуючи ці рештки,
ми можемо прослідкувати
історію розвитку видів і історію
розвитку зміни певних видів.
На минулих заняттях я
розповідала вам про еволюцію коней,
коли у них редукувалися
пальці на кінцівки,
і п’ятипала кінцівка первинного коня
перетворювалася на по суті
однопалу кінцівку сучасного коня.
Такі поступові зміни, які можна
прослідкувати у наступних поколіннях,
вони мають назву філогенетичні ряди.
Ось для коней такий
філогенетичний ряд відомий.
Відомий він і для деяких
інших живих організмів.
Наприклад, розшифрували,
відкрили, винайшли,
я не знаю як вдаліше це
сказати, предків сучасних китів.
Такими предками виявилися
чотирипалі наземні ссавці,
які мешкали у болотистій місцевості.
Їх родичами, тих давніх
тварин, є бегемоти.
Тобто, побудувавши весь
цей філогенетичний ряд,
можна прослідкувати зміни:
яким чином той прадавній бегемот
перетворився на сучасного кита?
Біогеографія та екологія – яким
чином вони допомагають нам
доводити положення еволюційної теорії?
Ми можемо вивчати розповсюдження
певної, наприклад, флори
чи фауни у межах планети.
Можемо порівнювати їх між собою
і за змінами між флорами та
фаунами на різних континентах
ми можемо аналізувати,
які біоми були первісними,
а які розвивали пізніше, враховуючи
гіпотизу дрейфу континентів, наприклад.
Ну, і зараз дуже активно використовуються
дані молекулярної біології та генетики.
Завершився проект «Геном людини»,
зараз у роботі знаходиться
кілька великих проектів,
які стосуються розшифровування
геномів різних живих організмів.
І ось порівнюючи молекулярні дані,
порівнюючи генетичний
код різних організмів,
ми так само можемо судити про
спорідненість різних видів генетично.
У ряді випадків, дані
молекулярної біології
перевертають наші догми щодо
розвитку тих чи інших живих груп.
До розвитку молекулярної біології
ми користувалися більш зовнішніми,
візуальними ознаками для того,
щоб об’єднувати групи в якісь таксони.
Насправді, родичами являються види, які
морфологічно можуть бути зовсім різними
і навпаки – види, які ми
вважали більш спорідненими,
насправді знаходяться
далеко один від одного.
Про це ми поговоримо докладніше вже на
наступних заняттях та у курсі «Генетика».
На сьогодні це – все
щодо нашого матеріалу.
І я хочу обговорити з
вами наступне питання.
Ми говорили про те, що еволюція –
це процес, який відбувається постійно.
Та чи можемо спостерігати еволюційні
явища ось зараз, тут, сьогодні?
Утворення нових видів ми
можемо спостерігати, чи ні?
Для яких організмів, яких видів?
Пофантазуйте, поміркуйте.
У шкільному підручнику
ви навряд чи знайдете
відповідь на це запитання, але спробуйте.
Я дуже сподіваюся на те,
що на наступному занятті
ми зможемо обговорити цю проблему.
Дякую, на все добре!